I'm Eddie Brock I'm a reporter I found  something really bad earlier to voice  Eddie  I have been what is that what do you  want about me and you slide out  you have no idea how much you're scaring  me right now  what the hell are you  we orphan  [Music]  I'm Eddie Brock I'm a reporter  I found something really bad I have been  taking  human games are disposable but man and  symbiote combined this is a new species  what do you want about me inside out  we cannot just hurt people  is by cliffs so many things so little  time  [Applause]  [Music]  cesium quill momento elevator voice  until uh dos fin soup elephant one table  did she say Jabba's Arthur L cannot have  my wallet  [Music]  POY afrontan super on de la Cite a  lactam Oh prima donnas Fida  on the technology cannabis opium in okay  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  ever  [Music]  Oh  you